I'm Christine Hamilton being the
returning officer had the election of
every partner for the Enfield on
parliamentary constituency hello
Thursday 8th of June 2017 do hereby give
notice that the number of votes recorded
for each candidate at the election is as
follows
Deborah Kerr and UK Independence Party
848 Nicholas decosta Liberal Democrat
1036
Nick Nick Dubois the Conservative Party
candidate
17900
Phil Linton remounting 574 Joan Marie
Brian Labor Party 28
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sorry I'll be sorry Almeida I didn't
finish it
28,000 177
[Applause]
the total number of ballot papers
rejected was 125 the turnout was seven
to seventy one point 13 percent I hereby
declare that they said Joan Murray Ryan
is the duly elected as Member of
Parliament for the Enfield North
Institute
[Applause]
thank you I joined the Labour Party in
1983 and I joined it because the values
and principles that he stands for
fairness for equal opportunities for
social justice and human rights for
respect and dignity for all a true sense
of community people working together
strong helping the weak I do believe
that we achieve more
I am common endeavor and we can achieve
the loan I think tonight the people of
Enfield North have also said that these
values and these principles matter they
do want to work together they want a
national health service that serves
their needs that's got good A&E
pathologies paternity facilities and a
GP appointment when they need one they
do want schools that are properly funded
teachers that are properly paid and
small classes where their children can
fulfill their true potential they also
want safer neighborhoods an appropriate
level of policing on their streets and
in their communities and they want homes
that are decent and affordable and
secure but they know that this election
was not about them it was not about what
they want
they need it wasn't about these values
it wasn't about their services this was
I'm afraid to say an entirely
self-serving election it was an
arrogance to call an election that
nobody wanted or needed other than to
resume and the Conservatives and I am
very very proud to be part of them field
and part of its community and to live
here and to work here and to represent
the best constituency in the whole
country and I will continue to do all as
I can to serve the people of Enfield and
I recognize that when we put before the
elektra a choice it is their choice they
choose us not us them and we are here to
serve them and we should have elections
where they know that they come first and
nothing else but their needs and their
wants and I spent a lot of time on the
doorstep and I am absolutely certain
that the people of our bills are very
clear about what they want and their
needs are and I intend to spend the rest
of this term of office in making sure
that I work as hard as I possibly can to
fulfill those needs
I'd like to offer my commiserations to
my fellow candidates and plant them for
a decent typing and a very hard-fought
campaign I want to thank the returning
officer and all these staff who has
conducted this election and it's been
conducted in a very orderly manner
I'd like to thank the police we've
ensured the security of this election
I'd like to thank my wonderful
absolutely wonderful election agent and
organize that avatar having a fantastic
job on to that bus and my family of a
lovely support I'd like to have all of
the EM field north and all the other
local party members and supporters who
come here and helped me enjoy this
victory tonight but above all else I'd
like to thank voters and field
[Music]
for an absolute authority
[Applause]